every day right you know you never know  what's gonna come with the live show  every day exactly of course we have this  awful news that just happened how do you  guys address it in the premiere today  yeah so you know unfortunately just like  everyone else we woke up to this really  horrific news out of Las Vegas and we're  definitely gonna address it on the show  because that's what TRL is it's not just  a place where we talk about music but  it's also a place where we're talking  about real life events so we're all  affected by this tragedy and we're  hoping that we can maybe be a place of  comfort for the children so from MTV and  TRL our prayers and condolences to  everyone in Las Vegas  [Music]